OK, hi everyone and welcome back to
another VC libraries Open code review.
I'm today we'll be looking at P12O6R7
conversions from ranges to containers.
Again, we looked at it during
the last video code review,
but as this is a very large PR adding
7186 lines and removing or modifying 275,
we did not get through all of it,
so I will try to get through as
much as I can in today's session.
As we catch up, uh,
after the previous partial code review,
my uh, submitted 6 comments and
then Casey pushed 6 commits here,
so I will try to see what has
changed in the last couple of weeks,
and then we'll resume reviewing.
So actually,
let me also expand what I commented
on as a reminder of what we looked at.
Remember, we looked at the list container.
We looked at some of the common
changes to X utility. OK, so.
Let's go to files changed.
Let's go to this.
PR is not quite as large as it seems,
because many of the changes are test code.
The actual product changes are less.
So I'm going to Alt click on the Chevron
and expand and then minimize everything.
There we go.
OK, so I'm going to use get here to
show changes since my last review.
This will select the last six commits.
Yeah,
including comments or changes in response
to our contributor miscoe's comments,
so that's great,
OK?
So we've got some changes to deck.
These are actually fairly large changes.
OK, so some of these containers
I haven't even looked at yet,
so I am not going to look
at for these recent changes.
Changes to the containers that
I haven't even looked at yet.
I'll simply review those when we get to them,
but we'll look at list and I think I
might have looked forward last time.
We'll look at forward list as well.
So we got forward lists.
We got lists there.
And then I see some elderidge
issues have been submitted,
and then we also looked at X utility OK.
I want to understand what's happening here.
OK, so these changes are not too big in list.
This is.
I remember a preexisting issue that I had
noticed where assign took two iterators.
So this is saying hey list.
I have a range of things I would
like to replace your contents
with this other range and before
we unwrap iterators like vector
iterators down to raw pointers,
we conventionally need to verify them,
which means we go through
a helper function in debug.
Code and this makes sure that the iterators
belong to the same parent container,
so you don't accidentally
say VEC one dot begin.
VEC 2 dot end unrelated iterators would
be bad and for random access iterators.
This verifies that the iterator
is not transposed,
they need to be in the order first
last and if you give us last first,
that's incorrect.
So that's what ADL verify range does.
And we need to call that before
unwrapping down to rough pointers
or something unchecked,
so that change is good.
That was a pre existing.
Thank you in forward list.
Let's see what's happening here.
So.
The new Prepend range function and
I do not remember seeing this.
This might actually be new to me.
We used to call the public function
insert range after and now Casey's
calling an internal function.
This is presumably being done for efficiency.
So call the internal insert range
after and tell us we're going to pass
our before head pointer to a node.
That's the internal replacement
for before begin,
and then instead of passing
the range directly,
we can get iterators into it and
they can be unchecked iterators here.
We don't need any verification
because with the range we know we
can grab first and last or begin
and end without transposing them
or getting wrong parents.
So ranges you begin is unchecked.
Begin our internal function range
ranges you in range, that's good.
Insert range after is changing.
It looks like a large change
because the classes are being
renamed apparently for consistency.
So template class inner class sent
for Sentinel iterator insert range
after because this is internal
Now this will take a node Porter.
This is our internal node pointer
type rather than a fully wrapped
constant iterator which participates
in debug checking and all that node
and interfirst concept in the last
insert inclusive first last
exclusive after P node.
Comment was correctly updated.
We don't need any verify because
this is internal and working
with unchecked node putter.
If the range is empty then simply
take that pointer to a node and wrap
it up in iterator and return it.
Otherwise do the same behavior,
but what we're being given
is just the P notes.
We don't need to say we're putter.
That's all good.
Then the public insert after
this is where the check moves.
So if we're in error debug level equals two.
Verify that the where iterators container.
This is how our internal function to find.
An iterator's parent container that
needs to be re address so it needs to
be the stood address of my permit L2.
This bit here I can't remember
if I talked about this in a
previous video code review,
but this is related to our.
Uh, compressed pair optimization,
to avoid storing allocators,
because if an allocator state list which is
the case for vast majority of allocators,
we don't want to spend an extra byte or
actually 4 or 8 bytes in the container,
and this lives in a base class to avoid
having too much machinery dependent
on things like the allocators size,
type and different type and all that.
So a lot of machinery.
But it all exists there for a reason if.
That where iterators
parent container is wrong.
We say forward list erase
after iterator outside range.
This is bug.
This was clearly copy pasted
from another function,
but it should say insert after.
I will remember this for the moment
I'll go comment on the full diff.
I actually forget what happens if I
comment on a sub range of commits.
I think it would work,
but I prefer to do it on the full diff.
I see that happening as well for
insert range after down here,
so I'll comment on that.
That's forward list otherwise.
This is fine.
We pass reporter to the internal function.
Here same check,
same incorrect assertion.
Return insert range after reporter and then
if we give a range we say you begin UN.
So this is fine.
It's only the sum.
Assertion comment I always check this
because the validity of comments
and strings and assertions they
are not checked by the compiler
and they are a common source of
copy paste errors or other things
that need to be modified.
But those changes are otherwise good.
Let's see what's happening in extra utility.
I remember talking about copy move in
and seeing that it was replicating all
the stuff that copy memmove is doing here.
This is being mostly centralized,
so if you're saying if you're calling
our internal function copy move in
first thing we'll do is we'll copy.
The move, we'll give it the 1st.
We'll give it first plus count for
the end and then the destination.
That's our result.
If the contiguous iterator output is a
pointer, we can just return it directly,
otherwise and then here.
Casey has a nice comment.
Result is unused,
so the compiler can optimize it away.
Return dest plus static cast art.
OK, so that's fine.
It is interesting that this does not
cause unused variable compiler warnings.
I would potentially have expected to see.
I may be unused, however.
Uh, unlike a preprocessor like an if dev,
Umm, the compiler can in theory see that the
if constexpr could conditionally use this,
so I'm not going to comment here as
long as there are no compiler warnings.
I'm happy.
And if there were compiler warnings,
we could just silence them.
Next up, copy and unchecked.
I remember there was talk about
or my talk about whether size
T was always the correct type.
This is now being templated
on an integer type size tie.
Then if def.
CPP Lib Concepts when that's available,
we can have an internal static assert
that this had better be integer like
it can't literally be as integral V
because this could accept things like
the 128 type that IOTA View uses internally.
But if we find at compile time that we are
eligible for the memmove optimization,
then we're definitely working
with things that fit in memory,
so we can Statcast to size T
without worrying about overflow.
What's going on down here?
There's talk about, UM.
Whether we needed some of
the static asserts UM,
and we decided that they were not necessary.
So that's why this is being dropped.
And same here.
This expression will just have to compile
and then this count can be constant.
OK,
so that looks good.
So now let's go to the full diff
and I'll comment on forward list
before I forget anything else.
And also I may quickly check to see if
there's any other copy pasted if there
if that exists in other files, then I'll
just want to say please audit globally.
OK, so it's forward list. We had.
Here, yeah, that's incorrect.
That's an STL verify.
So basically anywhere that says STL Verify
is that the first occurrence in this file.
It's 22.
Yeah, here it is. So I can
say it curves below and I'll
edit it if I find another. OK.
So. This function is insert after.
But the. STL verify message says.
Erase after occurs below.
For insert range after still says
erase after. Sir, right after.
OK, we got comment number one. Uh,
let's see if any other classes are effective,
so I'm going to pop open everything.
Let's scan 4.
Still verify how many currencies only 10.
That's not too bad. That's pre-existing.
Commented. The second one that
I commented on preexisting.
OK, here we've got a new one.
This one is debatable because
we just say list insert.
Here it was actually the member function.
I argue we probably should say insert range.
Uh, I'll comment here. I. This is.
Beta ball. Well, I'll say.
See.
Yeah OK, I'll say Umm,
this is trying to decide how to
phrase it debatably on issue.
But as this function is.
Insert range the estl verify.
Message. Should probably.
Say that. 2.
OK, let's perforate this.
This is debatably an issue,
but as this function is insert range,
the still verify message
should probably say that too.
Insert isn't exactly wrong if
interpreted as a general term and
not a specific function name.
If we had mentioned it in backticks,
then it would definitely need to change. OK.
I'll assume Casey will want to change that,
but if he thinks it's reasonable,
then I suppose I wouldn't argue too much.
And. Here we just have a very generic
comment string iterator incompatible.
I don't know if I like that.
That really seems like it was copy pasted.
Uh, but it was copy pasted from insert.
Insert just says string
iterator incompatible.
OK, we're following precedent.
Can't argue with that. No comment.
What's the final occurrence?
Here are replaced with range
that's two iterators and we say
string iterators incompatible.
Presumably copied from.
Replace Yep, OK, so that files question.
OK, so it's not a global issue,
it's just definitely two and
forward list and a debatable one in.
Uh, what was it list itself.
OK, so that's all still verifies.
Uh, now, let's see.
But there is to review.
OK, so I had apparently reviewed
algorithm and I will score.
I think our move some code
movement and algorithm.
Here's all the tests.
I'm just scrolling through
and then feature test,
macro test and algorithm hit
the code movement for get
final iterator unwrapped.
OK.
So now. Let's take a look at X utility.
Should be able to sign off on this because
I just looked at the incremental changes.
So this was the fusing of the ranges,
copying them, move on to simpler.
Now we looked at that.
Copy and unchecked.
Sentinel copycat this is where
we remove the static asserts.
Get Finder and wrap.
This is the code that was exactly moving.
It's the largest addition here.
Here we're changing the Sentinel
copycat called it copying my move on.
OK, so this I think we can now
call done since I do remember
getting through this whole header.
And then we looked at lists.
Spark this.
This has also changed since last view.
I I see what I see what GitHub does.
It's if I mark something viewed
when they cleared the check mark.
That's where that changed since
the last view comes from.
Interesting that I'd mark list
as viewed and not X utility.
I wonder if I had actually gone
through all of extra utility.
I could have sworn I did.
I'm a little bit nervous about marking
something as reviewed when I have not
actually gone through it exhaustively.
I had a comment on the very last
line that strongly implies that
I got through this whole thing.
Yeah, it's really this that I know.
I verified large code movement. OK,
I'm pretty sure I've reviewed this all file.
Try not to get too bogged down in obsessing
over what I have seen and not seen.
OK so list I believe I also
reviewed this whole thing.
I'll scan through it so we've
got the Sentinel Conn Sentinel.
Stood move first.
For adding the new tag constructors.
And inserting the initializer list here.
This is just unwrapping.
Remember, being confused
as to why it was happening,
but I didn't object.
Prepend range append range.
Assign and checked.
Now we're going through and looking
at how the nodes are being reused.
We've got the verify that was added.
This is also just unwrapping.
This is the new assertion I'm.
This might have even been pre-existing
or existing in the last year,
and I didn't notice it.
And then the final deduction guide.
OK, so I believe the list is good now.
Let's take a look at forward list.
I think that's the one that
I ran out of time last time.
Yeah, because I looked at it.
I was like, OK.
It differs enough that I do need
to spend a lot of brain cycles
making sure that it's all good.
OK, so if Dev CPP Lib containers ranges,
this is the new feature test macro I am.
Going to check that it is
actually the right spelling.
OK, both plurals that is looking good.
Yep, because if you say if DEF total
typo then it'll just never be activated.
Presumably the testing would catch that,
but you never know.
Completed on is this a container compatible
range for tie forward list tag from
range T then perfect forward range.
Refer frange construct my pair which is
the contains the allocator from nothing. OK,
then we need an F list insert after opt two.
This provides exception safety.
Insert OPP from our newly constructed getal.
Umm, use that insert opt to append
a range unchecked.
Here we take the range and
get unchecked iterators to it.
That's good.
So after we've attached all those nodes,
we can allocate a proxy and then
finally attach the nodes before head.
That's interesting that
we do it in that order.
Why do we do it in that order?
That's consistent with what we
did for the range constructor.
Can't argue with that.
The move constructor?
Yeah, that's totally different.
OK, that's good.
Next if you have arrange,
an allocator will be very similar.
First you construct.
My pair, which is that compressed air
machinery with the allocator and then
otherwise everything is the same.
It's too bad we can't delegate,
but we found that delegated constructors
have undesirable effects on codegen here.
OK, so that's all good.
Next we have prepended range.
If Dev CPP containers ranges again.
Template container compatible range
OK call this unchecked helper
insert range after or head ranges
you begin ranges you end OK.
And of course there's no end range for
forward list because we don't know
where the end is a sign sign unchecked.
This is being updated consent in the
can be passed by constant value.
This next can also be top over cons.
That's a nice correctness improvement.
Here this is just a cleanup.
Instead of testing my first next again,
we just started next.
Let's just test next. That's fine.
It's also not too invasive.
If I saw a lot of invasive cleanup
site asked for them to be separated,
and then here append range unchecked
Casey's moving you first because we no
longer need it. That seems reasonable.
It is passed by modifiable value
for some user defined iterators.
That could help things.
It should never hurt.
Umm,
same sort of change here.
Mark next is top of contest
reasonable OK sign range if dev
containers ranges template compatible
range assign range call assign
unchecked with you begin you end.
That's all good.
OK, we're changing access control here.
I want to make sure that we're not.
Having redundant access specifiers were
clearly public here for insert after,
so we switched to private.
Then we go back to public,
that's good.
OK, the reason I'm pausing is
because I was just thinking, UM,
we've had serious 23 changes here in
the if depths, but when we switch
to public and then define insert
range after that's unconditional.
This happens even in C + 14 mode.
But it's OK because this is
actually being extracted out. The.
Public insert after is going to call it
so it doesn't need to be unconditional.
OK, so there is some refactoring here,
but it's for a good purpose.
It's not just a random cleanup,
so it's fine.
OK, so extracting out private
machinery template on ITER and
possibly different Sentinel.
Turn the iterator insert range after,
otherwise it's going to look
very similar to the signature.
I'm sorry about that.
I'm considerate where it's going to be utter
enode then interfirst consentino last.
OK, insert inclusive first last
exclusive after P node comments
been updated at first is last
and we have nothing to do.
Return make it RP node.
Otherwise get that first insert after
Reiki helper from the allocator.
Chain up the new nodes to it by moving
1st and it's passed by modifiable
value and then once they're all.
Attached then attach after.
He noted the where and make it her.
This provides strong exception safety.
I think I had a question last time
about whether it was necessary, UM,
but that ended up short circuiting
because there's no better way to do it.
There's like no more convenient way to do
it like this actually is quite convenient.
It handles the loop for us,
so we're not paying any extra costs,
so this is fine. Public OK. Umm?
We commented about what's interesting
is if you look at the full division,
this is just change this being
damaged for no reason.
What's funny is that, uh,
the message isn't even right anymore.
UM, the message used to be right forward.
List insert after location
incompatible because the where
iterators parent container is not us,
then it's being changed to forward list
erase after iterator outside range.
But we're not saying erase after some range,
the where has no relationship to 1st last.
No, that message is actually really bogus.
Same with insert range after it
should be where is not compatible.
Yeah OK, I I need to expand this comment.
Additionally, UM that message.
Is changing from.
Location incompatible.
To. Better outside range.
But I believe that's incorrect. OK.
That this function is insert after,
but they ask to verify message
says erase after. Additionally,
the message is changing from location and
compatible to iterator outside range,
but I believe that's incorrect.
Occurs below for insert range after OK.
Casey know what I'm Speaking of.
And then all this stuff is being extracted.
Return insert range after we're putter,
unwrap first unwrap last,
because we've already adial verified OK,
so now the function is just being
reduced to do the verification.
Or sorry functions being reduced to an
ideal to check the container parent,
verify the range and then unwrap everything.
OK then,
if defc live containers ranges
we're in 23 mode and if template on
container compatible range insert
range after again no notice guard
because this is modifying function
you could easily call it and then
drop the return value on the floor.
We're going to insert after
consideration where range refer
frange when we're on IDL two,
make sure that we're as container
is equal to the status of my L2.
We talked about the message called
insert range after with where putter.
You begin, you end of the range.
OK, that's good.
And then finally a deduction guide.
UM,
if dev containers ranges template on
a ranges input range R&amp;G and a class
Alec that defaults to allocator for ranges.
Range value to RNG enable if
it looks like an allocator.
OK, that's right forward list from where,
uh, tag instructor range rifraf
Alec is Alec Prince Pren.
Reduce forward list ranges range
of value to range L OK,
this deduction guide is good.
OK,
so that's a forward list we got.
Listen forward list so I remember looking
at vector and thinking it was big.
Let's see shall we warm U with
another node like container?
Let's look at uh.
X trees the cot? Let's look at
X tree 1st and then map and set.
Trying to build up the
courage to look at vector.
OK, so xtree it's node base,
so it's gonna seem similar.
We are clearly public for insert and
then we're switching into protected
because our drive classes will
need to see this before we go back
to public template intersectional
avoid insert range unchecked
that our first consent analas
consult on my head is get scary,
which is our scary data structure.
Scary is a technical term actually.
My head. This points to the Sentinel.
Code for as long as we have not
encountered the last increment
1st and placement before my head.
The element to your first.
OK, that's how we insert nodes.
It's good. Go back to public.
So all of this is being extracted,
we verify and then we pass the unwrap first,
unwrap last and then this is going
U here exactly moving except for
you first being renamed at first.
That's good,
so it's being generalized if Dev
cclub containers ranges template
container compatible range for
insert range range for range insert
range and checked you begin range
you inrange just insert everything.
And effective containers ranges
OK for the input list.
We can call insert range unchecked.
And pass with pointers.
Yep, that's a nice optimization.
OK, X tree is good.
Let's take a look at the actual
drive containers map and set up.
Here's map.
So all the tag constructors are being.
Lumped together,
I'm here.
I'm not doing the exhaustive
out against the standard,
I'm just looking at the code
itself trying to make me see if
it makes sense and is consistent.
Umm, if people have containers,
ranges and if OK, so I'm gonna ask.
Review these template on container
compatible range for the value
type range map constructor
tagged from range T range.
Refer for range nothing coskey
compare of Pred Konski compare of
Pred Consolator type profile or
just console locator type profile.
This one should default to my
base key compare Pren Pran.
This is the type.
I wanna see if this is pre-existing.
We try to construct temporaries with braces,
but it is preexisting.
We do, say parents here, that's fine.
But if we have a period, we should use it.
We have a pretty now we should
use both if we have just the,
we should say key, compare it out OK.
And then this insert range unchecked,
give it ranges.
You begin range ranges you and range OK,
all those constructors are good.
Uh, next uh map has deduction guides.
Uh, while these guides are repose,
if dev people containers ranges endif.
OK, and it makes sense to stack these
within the has CXX 17 guard around all of.
Of the deduction guides,
generally we do not like
to nest these ifs too much.
We'd rather say if has 17 and
if if has 20 and if for like
just different member functions.
Even though strictly speaking
20 is a subset of 17.
However, 17 is when class template
argument deduction was added,
and it's natural to guard all of the
guides with 17 and then additionally
light up new constructors with the if Dev,
so this is fine and consistent with
what we do elsewhere, I think.
Template on ranges,
input range, RG class,
PR the predicate defaults to less
of the range key type of range.
Class Alec defaults allocator convert
range to alloc type range OK enable if.
Several criteria need to be met conjunction,
so PR had better not be an allocator.
Alloc must be an allocator.
OK this.
Any constraint prevents some
confusion between the.
Uh, possible guides when allocators
appear in different places,
even though it looks like it might
should not be necessary map if
you're deducing from range T range.
Rifraf PR has a default.
Alec has a default deduce map of range
key type, range range mapped type range,
the PRED, and the Alec.
OK and then here.
If you don't have a party at all.
Template on range. Class Alec.
OK, so let's see this handles nothing pred.
And not this handles what range range.
Prad range Pret Alec,
but we need one to handle range Alex.
That's why Alec appears here
without a default.
That's Alec.
And then Alec could better be an allocator.
Map has a constructor that
requires takes allocator.
And range key range range map type range.
The Articat will default to less
of the range key type range.
Exactly the same here and then the Alec.
OK, that guy looks good.
Multi map extremely similar changes.
I'm just going to be on the
lookout for copy paste errors,
but I don't expect to see any because
there's no like messages or something.
So key compare if you have a product, use it.
If you have prenatal, use them both.
If you have just all use key, compare now.
Then insert range.
Uncheck from the base class you begin.
You end if dev containers
ranges multi maps are deducing.
We get a compiler if any of this said map.
Otherwise,
the same defaults the same constraints.
Yep PRPR Alex Alec.
Yeah, that's all good. OK map is done.
Let's take a look at set.
OK, again,
extremely similar so I can sort
of speed through this.
I still got to lookout for copy paste errors,
but I don't think there's gonna
be any key compare.
If you have tried to use it right now.
Right now is key compare now insert range,
uncheck you begin UN end Yep.
Uh, these are the guides.
If defc build containers ranges here,
I want to make sure that nothing
was like incorrectly copy pasted
from MAM template on input range.
If the PR less of ranges
range value T OK here we don't need
that internal range key type thing.
You just get the range of value T.
But we do need to go into the
ranges namespace for that.
So that's that difference.
Alec is allocator for that thing.
Umm PR had better not be
an allocator allocator.
Should be an allocator.
OK, that's a good set of ranges.
Range value T OK.
And then if you only have the Alec.
It had better be an allocator to do set
ranges, range value T, lots of ranges,
range of value T and Alec OK, that's good.
Multiset key compare Pred Pred
key compare you begin you end.
That's how good guides are
deducing multi sets.
This is PRPR Alex Alec got
the same constraint here.
Got to be an Alec.
Yes, OK. That is good.
Now let's do unordered.
Humanize that,
that's xash.
OK,
again the same sort of deal where
we're going to call an internal
helper insert range unchecked.
Once we've got unchecked,
begin unchecked and so nice for efficiency.
Here we were clearly public for insert,
jump into protected,
then go back to public. Excuse me.
Template cluster class.
Sentinel void insert.
Range unchecked it refers consentino
last this is extracting the body.
Here we want to call the place
function member function
drfirst that's being extracted.
We still need to verify out
here and then unwrap both.
That's good.
We're still in public FDC flip
containers ranges template compatible
range for our value type range insert
range don't need to verify anything
just call insert range unchecked
you begin you end and then here
for efficiency insert range intact
eyelids begin ilist end awesome.
Yep that's right if DEF OK
let's look at unordered map.
OK, so here we've got.
A zillion deduction guides.
OK,
so there's enough here that I
gotta verify against the standard
because we've had issues even in the
standard with guides being missed,
so I want to make sure we don't
miss any here.
Let's take a look at unordered.
Map.
Also, I could have sworn that we have one.
There's one constructor that.
Was missing in the standard
itself and we implemented it.
And we have an LWG issue.
So the issue here is that if you look at
all of unordered maps zillion constructors,
it's sort of handling defaults like
if you don't pass a hash or whatever,
and as these things were added
over time due to an oversight,
one or two combinations were omitted.
Let me. Actually,
this is interesting and
interesting to talk about.
Let me bring this up so I've got a
bookmark for the LBG table of contents.
I'm pretty sure I filed this issue,
but it was not recent,
so it's going to be maybe near the middle.
I would have talked about probably unordered.
I don't know if I would have said
unordered positive there's 43 occurrences.
See if I can find this.
I would have talked about constructors.
Not preserve functions.
More missing allocator.
Extended constructors for unordered.
Yeah, this seems right, and it's new,
meaning it has not been addressed yet.
Oh this is Billy.
OK was not me. Thanks Billy.
We suggest where is the
current proposed resolution?
Adding constructors of the form
take a range and an allocator.
Take an input list and an allocator.
Provide. Definitions for them.
Same for unordered multi map.
Did we ever? We should also guides.
That's interesting, this doesn't mention,
oh, this issue probably predates CTAD,
doesn't it?
Yeah 2016, this may have predated the
class template argument deduction.
OK, so aside from that,
which I'm pretty sure we do have implemented,
that means we should check do we have?
Constructors for range and Alec,
and I think we do because
I see this from range.
So let's look at the paper.
Unordered mam from range.
OK, this is actually simpler
because we just provide.
But we provide one here.
OK, so it actually is
following the pattern of.
Let's provide several overloads.
That provide various defaults. Uhm?
And the one that's missing is range
followed by just an allocator.
It's not this one.
This one's got way too many arguments.
This is range size Alec.
Grain size hash your Alec.
It looks like the new proposal is
equally affected by this LWG issue,
presumably because it imitated the existing.
Functions are the existing constructors.
So because this.
Is not it's not the end of the world.
I don't know if I would write a comment here
saying that we should file an LWG issue.
It seems like we should because otherwise,
like I'm maybe the first
person to notice this, UM.
Perhaps we should point this out.
Uh, this got a forward citation
of 35 or six with that.
Missing ohh allocators think
structures for priority queue.
Yeah, let me check real quick to
see if UM, we come into 2713 in.
What is this unordered map itself?
Unordered map.
We didn't. I thought we just
implemented it, so let's look at
the unordered map constructors.
And it would be.
In a in an allocator as the
signature we're looking for.
Yeah, we just straight up implemented
it without actually commenting that
it's technically implementing a PR,
uh, proposed resolution.
And same with the the CTAD below.
Usually we we do like to comment that
I guess we just went ahead and did it.
Ah, let's see. This was, uh,
wasn't this one of Casey's proposals?
Yes, he was actually involved here.
I will add a comment.
Uh, it will be no change requested,
but I will observe that I believe that.
This is affected because let's
bring here is just range.
No, here's range in Alec.
OK, I'm confused.
Am I missing something or did
Casey's implementation just
replicate the thing that we did in?
Our code OK, so unordered map.
This one specifies from range range
and then immediately goes on to
size type, so that can't be it.
From range, range size type no.
Delegate from range range size type.
And then deduction guides.
OK, Casey is splitting out all of the
default args in different instructors.
That's following our existing,
but he is implementing the one
that is range and allocator so.
I will comment saying that I
think his implementation is
doing the exact right thing,
like we're replicating our extension,
but we really should at least mention in
this LWG issue that it's also affected.
OK, so let's comment here, UM.
It appears that. This paper.
I want to link to the actual revisions,
so I'll need the full number.
Doesn't mention. This. Signature.
But it's consistent with LWG.
27 thirteens proposed resolution.
And our implementation.
Where we added such instructors.
And the reduction guides.
Without any. Comments.
No change requested for this PR,
but I believe we should at a minimum.
Umm?
Contact the LBG and add a note.
2. Alderbridge 2713.
Whoo, I don't want to do that.
Now it's 2713. That
copy this. P 1206 R sevens.
New constructors are also affected.
That's what we get for not
solving it in the standard yet.
OK, so let me double check
these links open and open, Yep.
And yet more missing allocator
extended structures for our containers.
It appears that P 1206 R 7
doesn't mention the signature,
but it's consistent with LG 2713 proposed
resolution and our implementation
where we added such constructors and
deduction guides without any comments.
No change requested for this PR,
but I believe we should add a
minimal contact the LWG and add
a note to LBG 2713 the P.
1206 or 7's new constructors
are also affected.
OK, let's do the right thing.
OK, so let's make sure that each
of these constructors otherwise
has a reason for existing.
If Dev people have containers ranges.
So we have template on range in order
to map from range T just a range.
So let me switch over to highlight mode.
We've got this one so far,
the rest being defaulted.
Uh, my base uses key compare Prime
Pran allocator type print Pran.
This insert engine checked.
You begin, you end OK.
Then, if we have an allocator.
Here I want to scroll the right key compare.
We need to use that L.
OK, this is the one that does
not exist anywhere yet.
Uh, insert you beginning with.
That's always going to be the
same if you have buckets.
That is this one here.
Key compare allocator type.
Because we don't have an allocator here,
my base.
Yeah,
here's a good reason to audit everything
to make sure we don't miss something.
We need to rehash up to buckets and
then insert a bunch of stuff, OK?
If we have buckets and L,
that's not this one.
That's this one here.
Size Tye followed by allocator.
We can do that.
My base key compare use that L, use the
buckets and then insert OK if we have.
Buckets and hasher that's up
here buckets and then hasher.
Uh, my base, so you got a hasher?
Construct a key. Compare from hash Arg.
And then we don't have any
allocator allocator type on pren.
Use the buckets,
so we're using all arguments.
OK, good if you have buckets,
hasher, and an allocator Al.
So that's not this one.
There's no key equal.
Yeah, it's this one.
It's, uh, buckets hasher allocator.
Size type hasher allocator.
Yep, so that one. Umm, use the hash Arg.
Use the allocator. Use the buckets.
Insert OK, that's good.
Let's go back up here.
If you have buckets, hash your key EQ.
That's this. Then let's use the hash.
Argue the key eqr.
We don't have an allocator, though.
Rehash buckets,
insert and then.
If you have everything.
Buckets hasher key equal
and allocator buckets.
Hasher Key Q allocator
use all of them. Hash arq.
Argall buckets insert good.
OK, that was a lot, uh,
let's see now guides OK?
Guides can be simpler because we
actually don't care about the
values being cast as arguments.
Uh, let me go ahead and expand this now.
FFC flip containers ranges,
so we're templated on range
of support range range.
Here we can have some default hash here.
If you don't have 1 hash
of range key type key,
Q is equal to range key type Alec
is allocator range to Alec type OK.
It's interesting range to Alec type.
I want to see what this is,
but I do remember we used it elsewhere
trying to think like why would
the Alec type be different than?
Oh, that's right because it's a pair.
This will be OK. This will be V.
This needs to be pair of constant K&amp;V so this
alias is needed to form that obnoxious type.
OK, so that's good.
Enable if hash has got to be a hasher.
Because we have a specific concept for that
key, Q had better not be an allocator.
Alex should be an allocator that looks good,
so range. This guide size type
prevents deduction in certain cases.
We need that.
Hashire Q Alec OK so this
is the fully defaulted 1.
The deuce unordered map from range key
type range map type hasher key to Alex.
We've got all of them.
If we only have size type for
buckets and then Alec.
Then we have an unordered map of
key diet map Tye from range hash of
keytype equal to keedie because these
are all defaulted and then Alec OK.
If you have range and Alec,
we deduce the exact same thing because
the buckets don't influence anything.
Yep. That's all good.
And then finally, if you have.
And Hasher and Alec.
But no key EQ in there.
Then keidai map type, use the HASHER,
but provide equal to range key
type and then the given Alec.
OK, that looks good.
Unordered multi map.
OK so this is going to be highly repetitive.
Again I am not too concerned about
copy paste errors here because it's
especially between the multi containers.
It really is just a search and replace.
There's very little go wrong so I
will give this a cursory review.
We're always saying multi mapped.
Most I want to make sure we
don't forget the buckets,
so there's because that's
like the one line I see that.
We could forget and it would be very subtle.
Uh, we're using the buckets when it's there.
That's looking good. Yeah, that's good.
And then the guides again.
We should have those four guides before.
Yep, 4 guides before.
OK, so each of these unordered multi map.
Yeah,
of course we have to admit the same type.
And. This really should just be a search.
Replace key dot map type hash your
key because we have them all here,
we need to synthesize hash of range
key type equal to range key type.
But we do have the Alec.
Uh, here hash Range key 2 range key dibalik.
OK, because we don't have anything.
If we have the hasher we can use it,
but we still need equal to.
We can use the Alec.
OK, that's an order of map.
Let's take a look at unordered
set under 52 lines.
Again,
we can speed through this one fairly quickly.
This one's a little bit
different than the map,
but not too different.
So if we have nothing,
use key compare allocator type.
If you have the L, use it.
If you have the buckets rehash buckets.
If you have buckets, use it and all use it.
When I Scroll down I'll like to select a bit
and then that way I don't lose my place.
So, buckets rehashed hash
argues it buckets hashar al.
K buckets hashar key QR, but no L and then
finally buckets hashar key QR now OK.
And of guides we do expect 4 guides,
but now we don't need all that.
Uh. Type 4 allocator.
So if we have all the types,
we can just reduce an ordered set.
If you only have the allocator,
then we'll use it,
but we'll synthesize range of value T hash
range value T equal to range value T OK.
If you just have the allec again
exact same deduction. And then.
Here, if you have the hasher, use it,
but otherwise synthesize equal to.
OK, that's good,
and allocator defaults to allocator ranges.
Range of value T. OK, that's good.
It really is, it is.
Uh, less than awesome that there's
no way to say I would like him to
span out deduction guides for any
combination of parameters here and
including like defaults in the middle.
It's just the core language
doesn't have that,
and honestly this cursor rarely
the only place in the STL.
This weird like super spammy
set of overloads happens is in
the unordered containers.
This is by far the worst of
them because they want to make
so many things optional.
OK, and then on order multi again
very similar not to worry about
copy paste errors so nothing here.
Use the ASL. Use the buckets.
Use the buckets, use the L,
the buckets the hash Arg.
Buckets the hash argue the L.
Buckheads hashar key QR binol.
Buckets Hashar key QRL. OK that's good.
We've got induction guides again,
four of them.
It's always a murdered multiset. Yep.
And all the types it's emitting are the same.
As what we would expect.
OK, that looks good. OK,
so that's all the node based containers. Uh,
let's look at deck which is quasi node base.
That's a lot of changes.
And well, 234. It's not that much.
Yeah, it's more vector like
because we we need some.
Extra code here. OK so.
Priority, ignoring white space.
I'm already ignoring white space.
This is as good as it gets.
OK, this diff looks horrible,
which makes me want to switch to before
and after or side-by-side really.
Yeah, let's do that.
I'm reading this interleave
code is obnoxious.
OK, so let's switch over to deck.
What is this comment here?
Ohh,
this is Misco saying refactoring the
internal helper could be a separate PR.
Yeah, can't argue with that.
I wouldn't demand it,
but it could be separate.
OK, so uhm.
I'm actually I'm tempted
to view this in VS code,
but I think I can view this on
the right side of the screen.
My screen is wide enough here.
OK. So we're in deck.
My least favorite container.
If Dev, CPP, Lib containers ranges,
that is the correct spelling.
We have our new tag constructors
container compatible range as
the constraint construct from
either range reference range and
sometimes it comes out or found.
My pair, either nothing or L,
otherwise they do the same thing.
Construct an AL proxy tie.
And this is for leak protection.
As usual container proxy putter,
so we're going to install
this a proxy for our iterator.
Debugging into our get data.
Then construct from.
You begin you end Roxy release and
which will actually make it effective.
OK, that's good.
Here's the refactoring where
we're generalizing this Sentinel.
It could take conventional and
instead of saying initialize
first class input iterators,
the comment becomes initialized
from input range first.
Last. That's reasonable.
We're going to call and place back internal.
OK, so now we're adding prepend range.
This is, we got to make sure
we're in right access control,
which I'm assuming we are.
We are indeed public after push front.
Let's prepend range.
If Dempsey public containers ranges,
there's the end of the guard
template container compatible range.
Prepend range takes a Range Rover range.
OK, so we're going to do here.
I could compare against something existing.
This would look most like the insert,
but it is special case to exactly prepending.
I'll just review this because I'm
familiar enough with how deck works.
I think I'm familiar enough we'll see.
So first thing we do is orphan.
All we are inserting a bunch of
stuff to the beginning of the.
Deck deck has UM, interesting
requirements or specification that.
Inserting things at the beginning or
the end of the deck does not invalidate
pointers and references to elements,
but iterators can be fully invalidated.
This is because Dex elements are
essentially allocated in contiguous blocks,
but the blocks themselves are separate.
They're chunked,
and then the iterators can involve
an intermediate data structure.
In our case, what we call a map,
which is really just a vector
of block pointers.
That intermediate data structure
can be reallocated and that.
Even invalidate iterator so that means
deck along with the unordered containers.
The only STL containers that can
invalidate iterators without invalidating
pointers and references simultaneously.
So orphaning all is correct here,
even though we're only prepending and the
elements or otherwise remaining stable.
OK,
so next constant old size is my size.
Let's have a restore old size guard.
And we will pop from the front.
This is some new machinery we added.
I think this was Alex cutaneous
PR to remove Sphene.
I can actually let's bring that up
because that was an interesting PR.
Let's look at STL Inc deck.
Deck doesn't change that often,
so I'm pretty sure I'll be
able to find it quickly.
There's deck. OK, history,
it's definitely not my little operator.
Friendship is magic.
Here we go PR 2308.
Deck reraised to scope guard indeed.
From our contributor Alex Butenyl V UH,
which replaced. We used to have.
Uh, the old logic tribe again,
do a bunch of emplacement
if something bad happened,
pop a bunch of stuff, reraise,
meaning, throw, and then catch end,
and now we have RAII,
which makes the code a
lot clearer and better.
When exceptions are thrown.
And justice to save.
And it's got a.
You know, I'm,
that controls how we pop if things go bad.
So that's what that is.
So if an exception is thrown, we want to pop.
From the front because we are prepending,
we're going to call it guard. Uh,
initialize with this and our original size.
That tells us how much we need to pop,
so we don't need to otherwise
record any other information.
And then we have two possibilities.
If we have a bidirectional range,
then because we want to take our
range and we want to prepend it,
but we can only in place front,
then if we have bidirectional range,
we can start from the back of the range. And.
Uh, push front to replace front in order,
so that's what this is doing.
So if constexpr we have
a bidirectional range,
then auto uast is ranges get
final iterator unwrapped.
This is that code that got moved
constant to you first is EU begin,
so we don't need any checking.
We know it's a range while
you first Nyquil you last.
You last is the one that's being
modified here, but we always see
the order like first and then last.
This is this is good.
And then prepending order in place
front internal avoids any checking.
You last is.
Cast the end and we know that
we have a range.
You first is not you last,
so we need to unconditionally decrement
and then we're looking at an element,
and we can dereference it.
So this is correct.
Otherwise if it's not at least a byte irange,
then we have no choice
but to reverse direction.
So here auto you first.
This is the one that we're going to increment
is you begin comes out of you last.
While we have anything to do
in place front internal.
This says PREPEND flipped,
so we're going to, uhm.
If the range that we are prepending
contains the values 1020, thirty 40 if we.
If we in place front in order,
we'll end up with 1020 thirty 40.
So what?
The deck will contain at the
beginning will be 4020 or 4030, 2010.
I can count backwards that's flipped,
so we need to reverse it.
So after we have successfully
placed everything,
and this emplacement could construct
an object of a different type,
it could be consuming from an input iterator,
so we'll never get a chance to look at that.
Tell you again,
so we really do need to emplace,
but once we have that we can.
Do this stud reverse so this
requires the elements to be.
Assignable or swappable?
Uh,
I wanna say swappable for reverse,
UM I do want to check to see if
prepended range allows us to require that.
I believe it does because it's
similar to range insertion,
but let's check the type requirement
we can find out how many elements
without having to have account because
we can just ask what's our size.
So my size,
the current size minus the
old size that we save.
That's how many we just added.
We can static cast that to
different type store that
in NUM and then this is where.
We say stud reverse from begin begin NUM.
Uhm? It is interesting that this is begin.
This should really be unchecked.
I think we can say unchecked.
Begin here because like we're forming.
I'm decorator, like, uh,
they're expensive to check.
Uh, we know that we're
forming a valid range here.
Now it is true that deck has
not been thoroughly modernized.
We we really modernized vector.
We haven't spent nearly
as many cycles on deck.
This could be consistent
with our existing code.
Whereas the list has gotten some attention,
let's see looking at the OK,
like looking at insert.
Insert just says reverse begin,
begin, rotate, begin, begin.
We do not try to call
our unchecked functions,
so it's consistent with precedence precedent.
I don't think we're going.
I don't think I'm going
to ask for a change here,
even though I think we do have.
What is it unchecked?
Again.
Yeah we do and sometimes we use it.
Primarily in move construction.
Sometimes an assignment.
We're not super disciplined about it.
Sometimes, like a sign does.
OK, we're we're just halfway consistent.
Uh, we do use in spaceship.
It's new code.
Casey's writing a new code.
I think I I'll mention it.
OK Mr was asking about changes here.
Uh, the different changes.
I'll mention it.
How do I wanna phrase this?
I observe that. This.
Reversal is using checked begin.
But since we're forming this range
ourselves, we could easily use.
Unchecked begin. Uhm?
Deck appears to be. Currently.
Inconsistent. About UM
how much? Effort to apply towards?
Yeah, that's very verbose.
Currently inconsistent about
using unchecked iterators
internally whenever possible.
I see that some call sites do,
but not all. Consider this.
Uh, to be UM changes,
optionally requested.
I wouldn't. Object if you want
to keep this as is for now,
I can't really imagine that Casey would.
Say yeah, I want to leave it as is because
saying unchecked begin would be easy.
It wouldn't. I as far as I know,
it wouldn't have any other
propagating changes.
Just like a quick check to make
sure we always say unchecked,
begin and deck, but I won't demand it.
Deck is not a paragon of
performance to begin with.
OI observed that this reversal
is using check again,
but since we're forming this range
ourselves we could easily use unchecked
begin deck appears to be currently
inconsistent about using unchecked
iterators internally whenever possible.
I see that some call sites do,
but not all consider this to be changes,
optionally requested.
I wouldn't object.
If you want to keep this.
As for now.
OK, so after we flip your stuff I'm still
going to check the type requirement, UM,
regardless of whether we had bidi or not,
we have succeeded so we can nail
out the guards container, saying,
OK, we're going to commit to this,
and then we're done.
So let's check prepend range.
This would be in the probably a proposal.
I could check the working paper.
Let's see what the proposal has said.
It would have been a diff to either
deck or the container requirements.
I want to say it's probably in.
Let's check deck first.
And this was prepend range prepend range.
OK, this is talking about effects and
complexity, but not requirements.
So we gotta go to the overall
sequence container requirements.
OK, RG denotes container compatible range.
We're on prepend range.
Are these optional?
They're probably optional because
vector doesn't have it here.
Go prep under range.
Inserts copies elements range each
iterators difference exactly once.
No two *** note the order of
elements in RG is not reversed.
Thanks container deck forward list lists.
OK, that should have been monospaced, uh?
Or is the type requirement so
there is no type requirement here.
Interesting. Why are we not seeing this?
There's some, there's something that's
has something like this for vector.
Let's take a look at the OR is it? Umm?
Yeah, see like here. Assign range.
Yeah, so like if I say assign range.
I'm like a vector.
This says for vector if R is
neither sized nor forward,
T must be move insertable.
So this means if I can't instantly tell
how big the range is and if it's not a
forward range where I could just get
the distance and see how big it is,
then it's like an input only unsized range.
I have no idea how many
elements are going to be.
Maybe they're coming from some
sort of istream iterator,
so I need to repeatedly and
place back into a vector,
but that could reallocate,
so it's not sufficient for
the elements to be in place.
Constructible meaning in placeable
from the iterator.
They also need to be move insertable
because reallocation will move elements,
so that's where their type
requirement comes from.
That doesn't need that because
it doesn't reallocate.
It just allocates new blocks.
However, this flipping is a new operation.
Listen, let's see.
Listen forward lists don't need it,
because hold on.
List can link elements in the reverse order.
Now for lists can do that too.
We can traverse forward but
link them up the opposite way.
I'm pretty sure that's what it.
With that pre pen dots we if we have
1020 thirty 40 then as we consume
elements were like 10 and then we
change 20 we add them in forward order
and then we and then we fuse them to
the list whether list or forward list.
So there's no difficulty.
It's only for Dec only.
Deck needs to flip.
But there should be a requirement there.
Would that exist?
I'm trying to look for trying
to think about precedent.
Uhm, insert where comma first,
last should also have the same requirement.
Does it? I think let's see so.
Yeah, here we go.
Container insert where
iterator comma I comma.
JT's got to be in place constructable
if you're a vector in a deck,
you got to be move insertable,
move constructible, move,
assignable and swappable.
That's I think some of these requirements
are actually not always needed, but.
In general, some of them are
needed to reverse stuff more.
Ah.
Reallocate and insert range
does have that requirement.
So insert range is fine and it
should be called out there.
But Prepend I think.
I think this is a defect in the wording.
Clearly the implementation
is doing the right thing.
There's no other way to do this.
Yeah, that's a defect.
Deck needs that additional requirement.
Let's see if this has been patched,
otherwise I will ask Casey
to file an LDG issue. Ohm.
OK, it's not just a code review,
it's a standard review surprise.
Uhhh, OK, Container Library 424.
Let's let's see quirements.
They actually reformatted
reformatted this from a table,
a horrible table into something better.
I think it was optional.
Container requirements.
Nope, not that optional.
Umm? What was it?
Optional sequence container requirements.
I'm looking in the wrong place.
Uh sequence container.
Here we go.
We're going to maximize this for a second.
OK, so.
Like do not wanna highlight OK on selection.
We are on prepended range.
Here we go prepend range.
Preconditions T is in place
constructable required for
deck forward listen list.
OK so it is a defect in the
current working paper.
OK, so let's get the section.
Wow, paragraph 94.
I guess that's the downside of
breaking up that enormous table.
OK 24 two four sequence requirements.
OK, so prepended range I can comment
on the flipping. Which is this here?
There appears to be a. Wording defect here.
Ah.
And 4910 I'm pretty sure
I'm not transposing digits
there sequence requirements.
I can also cite the live
standard on eel dot is.
It was like paragraph.
What 94 something high, let's see. 94
text mines. Make big.
OK. Slash what? What 95?
97 says. A prepend range only
care about 95. And 97 whoops.
These are italicized.
I don't even need to look.
I do need to look for the
rest of the formatting.
UM, place Constructable is italics.
TX ranges begin, and the types,
so we've got. Tea. X.
Ranges begin range CP 17 in place.
Constructible is a towel sized.
Forward less and less. OK.
Alright, I was going to get
the short link to this.
21 dot link slash sequence dot
requirements load the live draft standard.
Scroll down to. 95
and 97.
No, that's gotta be square brackets.
It's like something's wrong here. 97
however, there should be additional
requirements for. Deck uhm.
Possibly only when the range.
Actually not possible because we can cite
the other one when the range is weak.
What was the precedent we
found it was the assign.
Can I find that quickly?
Assign assign range and there
I can point to the.
This is new wording.
So the insert one was even better
because that one talked about swappable.
Yeah. Interesting, this one doesn't say
uh about signed or unsupported was the.
I thought we saw wording that said if it's
neither sign or neither sized nor forward.
Uhm? Size range. Yeah,
here we go X from range RGB.
Assign range. Yeah, so it's really.
I would want to ask for both,
like this constraint about
neither size nor forward.
Actually here it is, not size.
We don't care about size,
we care about Bidi.
Umm if it's not bite I then
we gotta do the reversal.
Yes. OK, so we're going to
do where's the swap ball.
It was insert. Here we go for
vector index swappable. OK so 41.
Scroll up here and get the original text.
You can copy this. Same section,
so I'll just cite it as slash 41.
And instead of weak,
I can be specific and say
not a bidirectional range.
Not. Bidirectional range.
Similar to how 41?
Says I would say it requires
because that's the term of art.
Uh, preconditions, I'll chop this
out because we don't care. Da da da.
And chop out the range in a OK. I forgot.
So for vector and deck this is unnecessary,
but I do like my standard
citations to look pretty.
It's gotta be moving insertable into X.
It's got to be move constructible.
It's got to be move,
assignable and swappable is not italicized.
OK, we just swap requirements.
OK, and I did say similar,
so I'm not mandating excuse me.
That would be exactly that, UM.
I will phrase this as a question
should we file should we should?
Should we file an LWG issue?
OK, there appears to be a wording
defect here at W. 21 and 4910.
Seek requirements 9597 says a pretender
range preconditions T as in place,
constructible X range begin marks required
for deck forward lists and lists.
However, there should be additional
requirements for deck when the range
is not bidirectional and similar to
how 41 says preconditions for veteran
detectives also move insertable index move,
retractable, move, assignable and swappable.
Should we file an LDG issue.
Let me double check, uh,
these links make sure I didn't mess
them up so the working paper. Yep Yep.
Yep, OK, we're all good. Added.
OK, that was repent range for deck.
Let's see. We've got a little bit more time.
I think I can get through.
We'll see if I can get through deck if Dev,
CPP, Lib, container ranges.
Now we are appending range given Range
Rover Range again we want to orphan
all iterators because we are going
to modify the size of the deck by
emplacing consider old size is my size
auto you first issue begin consulto
ulas is you end restore all size guard.
We're going to pop if things
go bad this old size.
Four, as long as first does not last,
increment you first and
place back everything.
If it succeeds and all putter,
OK, nice and simple.
In place fun front we can refactor
to column place front, internal.
Overhaul in place for internal
doesn't care about orphaning.
Then we do this.
This should be a pure code movement
and in 17 mode we return front.
OK resize.
OK, so resize the refactoring here.
We need to orphan all because in place
back internal is not going to handle.
I'm assuming when it's extract it's
not going to handle any orphaning,
so we should do a single orphaning and then
in place back and that's the reasonable.
It's better than repeatedly and
placing back in that orphan,
that's why we didn't bother before,
so that's actually an improvement.
OK, so we've got in place
front internal here.
We've got large code movement.
I always want to make sure we're not
damaging code 99% of the time you're fine,
but we gotta catch that one.
Percent where things are damaged,
so I'm going to copy.
You can't see what I'm doing.
Let me move this over here.
So this is old and lace front.
Old and place front.
Shouty comments remind me that it's not
actual code change to CPP that's control KM.
Here's new code.
OK, is that the same level of invitation?
The code is so good enough. OK, let's differ.
And what do we get here?
We get a little bit of OK,
so there is some change,
but it's OK. Change UM,
this is now templated on class data.
dot ties, void under score and place
for an internal taking ties valves we
add cons to the size type block that
is an improvement because we don't
modify that and then clang format.
Readjust the spaces, the type and the
arguments are now ties and valves.
This name is new.
We've never said ties before.
I think we usually say types.
Size is actually fine.
It's probably better than what we've
been using. I have no objection.
OK, so that's a good code movement.
Umm, OK. Let's expand again,
Umm, so we just did in place.
Front internal. Uh, now?
A sign I'm assuming we're going to.
OK, we're extracting something
out assign range.
Which is essentially the
common version of a sign,
but can handle different Sentinels.
That's why this exists.
OK,
so we were public.
Implementing pop back, so that's fine.
Uh, we're going to jump into
private and then go back to public.
OK, so template class inter class
sent void under score sign range
take interfirst consent last.
Same orphaning but instead of addl
verifying and unwrapping and unwrapping,
we're going to assume.
That first and last are already unwrapped,
because that's.
What happens here?
We verify and unwrap or just pass
unwrapped O that's why we don't need to
verify and unwrap here we do need our
own unchecked begin and unchecked end.
OK, so now the comments are changing.
But the overall structure of the code is not.
It's changing a little some of the
some of the increments changing so.
This overall thing is trying
to reuse elements.
We used to say try to assign over
an element in the container and
then if the container is too.
If we run out of elements,
we need to insert at end.
So actually the control flow
is changing here.
The control flow is changing.
It used to be try to insert everything,
but if my first. Is equal to my last.
Then I've run out of container space South.
I need to inplace everything at the end.
And then once we're finished consuming
values, UM, if we're still not if we
consume all the values from the input
range without running out of space,
the container we need to cauterize
the container and chop off any
elements that we don't want.
So that's why the erase last is here.
This is now being inverted,
so there is a significant
control flow transformation.
I have no objection to this,
but I want to make sure that I reviewed
carefully, because this is where bugs occur.
It's so easy to mess up control flow.
So here as we iterate,
if we run out of elements to consume.
Ohh and what's interesting is actually
iterating over elements in the container,
not elements to consume.
So that's why this is being transformed OK,
and so this comment.
These comments are good, reuse existing
elements versus allocating elements.
I'll double check that.
OK, so same philosophy, but everything
is being sort of flipped around,
and the overall result is about as long,
maybe a little bit.
Sure, so four we've already initialized.
As long as my first my own container
first is not equal to my last.
And then as we proceed,
we're going to increment my first,
so we're looking at every spot
in our existing container.
As long as we have existing elements,
we're going to increment my
first look at a new value,
and we're going to increment first,
which is the thing that we're
consuming from the input range,
and we want to put a void cast in there
to avoid overloaded operator comma.
So we know that we have elements
in the container,
because that's our loop condition.
But if we run out of elements from the
source range first equals last, then.
This is the cauterization step where
we have extra elements that container.
Potentially we should get rid of them,
so we're gonna call erase last
end static size type my last,
minus my first because we've
incremented my first.
So my last minus my first is the remaining
number of elements, so this is correct.
It's still correct.
After doing that we should return.
But if we have not returned,
then we have an element in the container.
We have an element in the source
range we should assign to it.
Do our first, assign that to.
Do our my first,
then we're going to increment both,
so that's good.
This is very structured.
I like it.
And then if we have.
Used all the existing elements
in the container and we have not
yet exhausted the input range.
Then we need to allocate new elements
for remaining tail of values.
This is fine.
Allocate new elements.
It kind of implies there's
an allocation in deck.
There generally is every
16 elements or less.
This is fine. I don't think it's confusing.
If if this function we're concerned with,
like memory allocation directly,
I would want comments that distinguish
when we're allocating versus not,
but this is clearly implying an allocation
some of the time, so this is fine.
So for now we're gonna consume
elements from the input range first,
Nyquil, last, increment first,
then just in place back internal,
and we've already orphaned.
So this avoids extra orphaning.
That's good.
OK, so now go to public template.
This is the existing ITER
need to enable if iterator.
This prevents ambiguity with a sign like
and copies of VUM so sign for slash,
verify the range, unwrap them,
good if Jeff split containers ranges
endif assign range is constrained
call you begin UN no verification.
OK, and now.
Insert looks like it's
getting refactored as well.
We now have an enum class
is bytyqi backed by a bull.
Defaults to no one, yes.
No, should be fine now.
We used to have a problem with macros,
which is why the STL
currently says Nope and yes,
but that problem was fixed in
an unrelated project upstream,
so we should be able to say no again.
So this is being generalized to handle.
Iterator and arbitrary Sentinel.
But we also need to be told is by dye.
Because we've got if constexpr down here.
OK, and we've already seen the requirement
in the global wording about needing to swap,
so I don't think we need to double
check that here, so this is still.
Well, let's see,
are we still doing private helpers?
Yes. OK, so we're in private here.
So template is bite.
I intercement turn iterator insert
range and instead of taking where we're
going to say off an offset concise
type off and then interfere set last.
It is interesting that last is modifiable.
Everywhere else last has been consed.
Are we modifying?
Last comment, use it.
Use it. Oh, we decrement OK,
so we do actually need to.
So that's why it's modifiable.
That's good.
This is a good consequence of
consistently marking value parameters.
This constitutes when they're not.
That indicates getting modified.
Insert inclusive first,
last exclusive at begin, plus off OK.
Uhm, so the comments has changed.
We already have off, UM.
We still want that iterator
debug global check.
Get hot resetting, Umm, comments good.
We've calculated off got the ideal check.
We don't need a deal verify because we're
gonna assume everybody's on ramped.
Umm?
But we do want to see if we're going
to insert nothing if first is last.
Then presumably this protects
something below that would be wrong.
Also we do skip orphaning so first
is last you're asking us to do
nothing so we can form an iterator
return begin plus Statcast difference
type off OK because if you insert
nothing you haven't invalidated so.
That seems fine, so no verification.
Early exit old size can now be confused.
That's good.
Do orphan all.
If off is less than old size
because we've captured old size,
so this is actually just a straight up.
Umm, clean up slash improvement.
Why call my size again when we have old
size close to front push and rotate?
Ah, but there's an improvement here.
Previously, we would always in
place front and then reverse,
and now Casey is using our magical
powers if constexpr to avoid that.
At the end, we'll do the flip.
OK, this is good.
This is actually improving.
Interestingly,
it's improving the behavior of existing code,
and for a common case,
because biday iterator is the most common,
because the random access and
pointers are also bidding.
If constexpr bidi equals is bidi,
yes,
this is the advantage of having a named
enum class consume all the elements in place.
Front internal.
Dref redeck last,
so that's going to look at every
actual element prepend in order.
Yes, because. By Prepending from
last they they end up in order.
I'm trying to make sure the
comments aren't flipped.
Otherwise if you're not by dye,
then you just need to in lace
front starting from first,
but it ends up flipping
the order of elements.
OK. And then.
Here we have at least attached
all the elements,
so we nod the guard.
It is interesting that we decide to
do this and then we start reversing.
I assume that swapping is required to be.
All these swap they don't assign.
So these this is actually no throw down here.
I was wondering what happens if you
successfully in place all the stuff,
but then an exception is thrown.
I don't think we have to worry about that and
certainly the existing code wasn't OK, so.
We calculate NUM.
Why do we need numb?
We need from mid.
We definitely always excuse me.
We always need that.
We're doing insert range OK so.
Uh, this is now going to be auto
because this could be some arbitrary
sort of size type like thing.
Consolato NUM is static cast difference
type my size minus old size consolato my
first is unchecked again because we're
not working with iterators anymore.
We started with offset.
OK so NUM is.
The number of elements.
My current size minus old size that we
just in placed my first is unchecked again.
My mid is my first plus NUM.
If we are dealing with non
bidirectional iterators then we need
to reverse stuff so stud reverse
from my first to my mid so our
current beginning to the end of the
new elements we need to flip them.
So that's right.
And then.
Now that we've got the right
elements place we need to do a
rotate to actually get them to the
right position given the offset.
So that's the stud rotate,
which we were always doing before my first,
my mid my mid plus off these are unchecked.
So here Casey is using unchecked iterator.
So that's also an improvement
compared to the oh this is this
is the some of the president.
I was looking at was like oh
there's a bunch of begins.
Well, they're actually turning into unchecks,
so.
There actually is some down here. Hi Michael,
Michael back and edit that comment UM.
Because it's sort of a semi global thing.
This one certainly doesn't need to change.
I'll maybe just comment this one, uh,
because that's the only other case.
I'll look at this in a SEC so stood
to rotate from my first to my mid.
It needs to go to my Microsoft.
OK that's good and then
synthesize the return iterator.
OK, So what was this?
This is if it's close to front,
push to front, then rotate.
Otherwise this is the opposite.
Restore back.
For, the iterators aren't checked here,
I'm comparing first or before
to after OK the rotate.
This is just getting horribly reformatted.
Began OK, so this code is really not
changing at all and then return off.
OK, that's good.
I was going to check to see how
many other begin uses there are.
Comment return unchecked.
Begin return.
This is the one that's gratuitous return.
Umm, I'll comment on this.
I observe that these could also use.
Unchecked begin.
As the rest of the function is being.
Improved like that.
I observed that these could also use
unchecked begin as the rest of the
function is being improved like that.
And here we just don't happen to
have unchecked to begin out here.
We could actually lift this up.
Oh no, we couldn't.
We needed to have it after we've been
placed otherwise we get invalidated.
But we could just call and check again,
or case he could lift it out here.
OK, so I had a comment.
OK.
And then simple extraction
here go to public template ITER
constrain to be an actual iterator.
Insert first last at where input iterators.
This this comment used to
exist when we had tag dispatch.
Do we still need that?
And we weren't dispatching here.
I question whether we need input iterators.
That's the only comment in this
file that says input iterators.
Old code, old code.
Yeah, this is the only new one. UM,
I'll simply ask, do we still need the.
Input iterators comment.
Since we're not dispatching on.
Iterator. Strength. Here.
Car.
We're handling. My diness we're
handling. High directionality,
UM within the upper function, OK.
I don't want to say comma.
I wanna say comment part because
I only want to talk about that.
But do we still need the comment
input iterators come into part.
We're handling bidirectionality
within the helper function.
OK, so template iterator enable if
iterator iterator insert counselor aware
it first and last insert inclusive
first last exclusive at where input
iterators probably don't need that.
Verify the range then we should unwrap.
On size step off is static
cast size type where which is.
Regrettably, checked minus begin.
Return. Insert range. Static cast.
To is bite eye when does ohh I see
is Biti interv is our helper to see.
Are you Bidi iterator but
we need an enum class.
So we need a static cast that is byte.
This assumes that his bite eye occurs
in the order false true, and it does.
It starts with no.
It says no, and then yes,
so false is zero.
True is 1, so that's fine.
So we can static cast. And then.
Off getting wrap first get unwrap last.
OK, that's good.
If Dev cycle container ranges template
on range iterator insert range.
Consider aware Ranger for range. Umm?
We don't have a parent check here.
We don't have a.
We have a parent check here.
Ah OK, it's happening within
the subtraction iterator.
Subtraction will check that they
belong to the same container,
so we don't need an explicit parent
to check for where, so that's good.
OK, so where range still want
to form concise type off?
Same way if Constexpr bidirectional range.
Then OK, we do need special cases here,
because if you're bidirectional
you can say insert. Yes, it's bite.
I give the off range as you begin and
then ranges get final iterator unwrapped.
Because if it's bite I we want the
so it's what Casey's doing here is
if the range is bidirectional then
what we want to pass is the actual
final iterator to that past the end
element that we can decrement even
if the Sentinel with some other type.
So that's what ranges get final
iterator unwrapped, does and why.
We're not simply saying you end,
but if we're not then we can just
pass the Sentinel unchecked.
So. That is good.
This occurs infrequently enough.
I'm wondering should we have a
function that just handles this,
but this seems to occur infrequently
enough that we don't need.
A helper function to do that,
and then the last change to this
file if declic containers ranges,
we got a deduction guide template
on input range range.
Class Alec is allocated for
ranges range value T enable.
If Alex got to look like an allocator
deck from range T range ref ref.
Alec is Alec front prend deduce
range value T and the Alec Endif
CPPIB containers ranges looks
good conversation was this?
Variable templates ohh yeah,
we don't have an allocator VUM
OK so that's DAC excellent.
So we've got 7 more comments.
Uh, let's see.
I would want to actually mark that as viewed.
Let's minimize everything.
I do want to summarize,
let me open up my editor because I.
Was trying to remember what I had reviewed.
Uhm, OK, so let's split this.
OK,
so.
I'm just going to. Record algorithm.
We've got deck. Poured list. List map.
Sat unordered. Map and set.
For unordered meows,
I call them U MX hash.
Xtree extra utility.
5 Valves Core H.
None of the tasks.
And the feature just backwards does.
I'll just say feature test macros tests.
And for my own organization.
I will group these that is
extreme map set that's X hash.
You map you set.
OK. Great.
And I will submit this review.
Another partial video review.
Fee and more progress.
I've reviewed. Blah.
I should have marked down this.
I can do this faster in VS code.
I love multi multi cursor editing.
Uhm, I won't bother, UM.
Actually, some of these those
underscores might be yeah, fine.
I need to tell it that this is marked down.
And I want to. I shift click now.
Can I control click no? Not doubleclicking?
Interesting, I'll just go like this.
Tell. That was correct, OK?
Review another partial video
review and more progress.
I've reviewed all these headers and
then featured this macros tests comment.
OK. Hesitating only because I
know if I write a comment here,
this cannot be collapsed later,
but that's OK.
It's not too verbose, I'll comment.
OK, So what we found.
To summarize, we found some comments or
some assertion messages that seem to be
completely damaged during copy pasting.
This one was the same sort of deal.
We found signatures being added that
are consistent with our implementation,
but we really should update
an LWG issue for it.
We found that we could be calling
unchecked begin in a couple more places.
We found a wording defect
in the standard itself,
saying that elements need to be required
to be swappable under certain conditions.
Another unchecked begin and
then finally a comment.
So overall nothing major.
If anything,
we found more issues in the standard itself.
And just some assertion messages.
So overall this is looking real good so
far we are slowly getting through this PR.
We will see if I can finish
reviewing this or if we will have an
unprecedented Part 3 for video review.
So I hope this has been interesting
and we'll see you next time, thanks.